means like he said you need to move with
the times because people may have the
similar foundations to what they would
have had before but the ideals and what
the way people see the world is
different so you need to communicate
with them differently so we can't just
try and discipline people the same way
and give them certain models that no
longer are valued in the world that
they're in today because as much as you
want to influence that person there's a
million other people and a million
different things that they see every
single day that influences them even
more than you you're just one voice out
of so many so again like he said it's
about evolving with the times we can't
go back sorry how did you evolve what do
you mean evolved I think we need to
express the fact that the new
generations believe extremely in the
freedom of expression the freedom of
self you are who you are you have your
opinions that's why a lot of people
so if people are believing freedom of
expression believing in the freedom of
self you need to actually speak to
people in a way where you still going to
say to encourage that but you're going
to also try and supplement that you
can't force and you can't say this is
how it should be this is how it's going
to be instead potentially start doing
things a little bit more entertaining
that that communicate with what they
know because one thing that again I was
a teacher I know that you know
I was a special education I'm trying to
like measure myself with anyone I'm
explaining things from my experience and
what my perspective on this is the point
is people switch off the moment that
things don't seem interesting to them so
you need to speak to them on the level
and speak to them in a language that
they speak that's why he'll say people
right now if you go as an adult I've had
to had serious challenge with kids
because they don't respect my authority
because I'm an adult because it starts
at home
do not go against some of the ideals
that your parents brought you up with to
an extent but all I'm saying is your
life someone said at the start this
whole thing your foundations they start
at home whatever you learn if your
parents are swearing 24 7 you're going
to pick that up if your parents are holy
you're gonna pick up whatever you now go
to a different Community or whatever and
you learn from that Community it's then
now up to you to decide what you're
going to do kind of thing I look for my
stuff at home the foundations and yes
I've learned from other people but if I
now go with what I've learned in my
communities where I grew up I'd be
Wayward right now yeah and that's the
facts of the fact the issue now is that
people both parents work now so people
kids are raised by the state like we all
got our idea of how uni was from
American Pie we get our ideas from
dating from TV we all get I so I you
know as much as I understand Auntie
sentiments I think you can't really turn
back that clock for a number of reasons
you don't really have lifetime jobs like
that so people way more mobile than they
used to be you know there's all these
those International factors that that
kind of mean that communities can't
can't be as stable and lost as long as
they used to be back here
oh XYZ kid has got this phone that's so
important let me tell you one thing let
me tell you one thing the meta verse is
coming let me tell you one thing can you
control what your kid like you don't
have to have your kids have a phone and
also like if you don't if you don't like
this if you don't like the school system
I mean I don't know how it works in the
UK but like in the US you can homeschool
yeah
and you can and you can raise them in an
environment where you like you have
relatives and you have good people that
are influencing them around like around
them
who wants to be friends with their kids
you're not friends no no actually my
friends
because a lot of these people are having
kids while they're still kids themselves
that's the problem that's one but plus
two when this new modern day where it's
like oh
yeah
whatever but at the end of the day you
gotta discipline your kid and they
should discipline each other bring back
bullying
if you weren't called ugly once in your
childhood it was too good
how humbling them
that's why I think it's so important to
have like masculine role models in in
culture because I think right now a lot
of our issues are from you know the
mainstream media kind of feminizing men
yes and so these boys are growing up I
was a teacher
themselves
wait what are you talking okay what do
you what do you explain I'll explain
shortly and like five sentences
nowadays nowadays men are just like us
Petty men are just like yeah because we
we made them that way no because because
no no no
how many times has girl have girls said
I want a guy that's emotionally
available it's crazy because we only
fight for men's rights when it benefits
us because we like we want them to be
more emotionally available for us we
don't like that he's not even about so
that's why we tell many men are not the
ones leeching off the woman like that's
feminine to me okay okay
if you like bums speak for yourself
everywhere
I think it's just the guys that you date
are bombs so you can you can speak for
yourself
no no stop stop stop stop stop
go to South London my sister okay okay
oh my God like if you're dating bums
that's on you that like most women are
more broke than men even if they out
earn and we outspend them we make 70 to
80 of consumer buying decisions we own
two-thirds of the world's debt we we
don't make good monetary decisions how
are you gonna go to men and say you guys
are the broke ones we're the broke ones
you don't know how to manage our money
and we make less in the UK I don't think
it's quite like that a lot of women in
the UK actually you're right yeah just
whatever no no okay you're correct
you're you're correct you're correct
like like some women under 30 like do
out earn men in certain cities but we
still outspend them so it's like you
think you're the [ __ ] but you outspend
them well I make my money I'll spend for
me and then not only that because we are
spending because we got Financial power
then that's why a lot of men now see
that as a plus and they start leaching
off it again feminization no no no if
you like bombs speak for yourself
that's a small minority
yeah
can I say something so basically like
let's go back to traditional homes so a
man is basically like he's the head of
the family he he like pays for
everything right or like sometimes if
your mom wanted to go grocery shopping
or get stuff for the house or manage the
house your dad would give her the money
and then she would manage it would she
not like she would be like okay this
goes for groceries this goes for this
this goes for that so how could you say
like women are bad at managing money
because because statistically we are we
hold most of the words world's debt and
we make most of the consumer buying
decisions we hold most of the world's
debt that's why we're bad with money
even though we make less money where is
it found it you can you can literally
it's a worldwide we all hold two-thirds
of the world's debt or the world's debt
worldwide
anecdotally how many of us have our
freaking nails done here let's use the
anecdotal like that's what I'm saying we
spend money on stupid [ __ ]
what did she think she ain't said
nothing
about the conversation yeah but what
part there's been a lot of difference
all right so about like girls like
spending money on junk and stuff like
that would you do you agree with that or
yeah I feel like the the
um world that we're living in at the
moment is like really consumer based
that social media adverts you talk about
something it pops up
um I don't know too much about
statistics of men and women but I I
believe yeah can I make a point where a
lot of times the the phrase the world is
being used a lot the world the world the
world I think it's important to say that
this is largely the modern West thank
you yes this is not the majority of the
world I'd even say that it's very big
city based right the londons the New
York cities the LA's the Miami's the
mentality and the society and the
culture there versus even within the
same country in in more rural areas or
smaller towns or Villages the mentality
is very very different let alone in
developing parts of the world so-called
second and third world countries you
know there's different types of people
everywhere but the mentality is very
different I think that a lot of this is
very much based on actually a small
microcosm of society and we're speaking
as if this is kind of like everyone and
I don't think it is I I think it's the
it's the I would say big city Modern
mentality I would say I agree with you
100 like because obviously for my
experiences and everything I already
talked from UK London and in the USA But
the thing is with um the western side of
the world the areas you're talking about
they have the biggest influence yeah
it's relevant to talk about these these
regions yeah I know I'm certainly saying
it's relevant I'm just saying I think
think it's important to be aware for
ourselves and for the audience that this
is not the it's not like a global Norm
a lot of what we're talking about is
actually a global anomaly even when
you're talking about you know oh you
know these single single mothers it's
like that's not the global Norm the USA
has the highest single Parenthood rate
in the entire world right USA number one
that's probably not one that they should
be too proud of I mean in many many
countries like it's it's very rare yeah
even now in 2022 it's rare yeah because
there's no countries if you're a single
mom you're done you're done bro like
yeah yeah it's also the culture though
it's what's normalized yes you know and
I think one one of the big issues we
have in the west and it goes beyond this
issue but it's like we don't even strive
for a good standard anymore as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible